and good to go yeah good to go
so good to go is there gonna be an intro
or something or we just roll it into it
I don't know we can we can just go just
go just go the expert here okay
yeah you are the expert yes I am I'm
that horror guy the one of many is I'll
read the story for you because I don't
know you and her friend you and you
friends are on a trip and your car
engine stops you go to a resort for
shelter the doors locked behind you and
now you must escape your mission is to
escape the resort the first objective is
to break five crosses and then to escape
from the resort got all that should we
escape from the resort I'm not sure
you're clever bastard but I think we
should go hey okay you started whacking
it I figure that I thought that's how
you started what are we i we press the
button it what it's a button it's gotta
be if that is about a wait a giant
button duh
how do we start this game like an item I
don't know I don't know so it's just you
and me for all eternity
uh-huh lightly I finally have you I'm
not sure I want to procreate with that I
want you oh not this you don't want none
of this sexy this right here I mean it
might think measures measures I see the
way to go I see it I'm stuck inside the
button whoa that button it finally
worked no this this is just something
stupid something broke in the most
recent version of Gary's my it didn't
work so whatever whatever was good
you're at the start of resort yes hell's
resort so that CaptainSparklez over here
can get a taste of what I do which is
[ __ ] or are you ready done some horror
you know some splendor splendor you're
in there man or
I do it for a living man so you're gonna
be guiding the way I'm just gonna give
you friendly advice think of me as Navi
on your shoulder just hey hey walk
through that door over over I said like
more like sad like herbert the pervert
more than navi Donei so well wait were
you giving me friendly advice in that I
should walk yeah let's go in the storage
room I know you're like you're gonna be
a jump-scare there because you know okay
okay okay nothing I see I see you you
see okay laughing okay so as you can see
by that thing up there we need to break
the Devils crosses okay what are the
devil's crosses look like they look like
crosses oh really
devilish okay so we like go through the
map and like find them or something yeah
I thought there was one in one of these
but maybe broke itself oh yeah that
sounds about right
okay we're going good job good job team
we did it let's go into here I bet this
is a place where Devils crosses are oh
boy I bet so let's go into the
numerically ordered room of one through
six over there okay let's do that we
should probably do that
oh god this is why you're gonna go in
the every single way out yes just
because just because you are too scared
to do it yourself
hey ow hey
actually you're not even close this cuz
I have making you go at every door go in
that door okay go in that door I'm going
in this door okay it's kind of kind of
shaking it's kind of shaking a little
bit
yeah are the devil's crosses present and
they should be somewhere not funny okay
all right so anyway we just need to hit
through these rooms I don't remember
which ones have jump-scares in them so
I'm just gonna be following you the
entire time
all right and I'm just gonna be breaking
boxes to try to find you missed
something here it's like it's a
pentagram and oh god I'm glad I wasn't
standing on that thing or I probably
would have been impaled yeah did I did I
find a cross the thick baby the cross
didn't spawn in really that's okay it
doesn't matter just pretend that either
the cross here and ah your mother was a
hamster
[Music]
hey hey I was trying to grab you
minecraft is stupid
whoa whoa okay all right you killed me
Matthew
The Devil's cross oh that wasn't me
talking by the way oh
the dole just like building penises in
Minecraft yes I'm a professional penis
builder in my you know yeah because I
mean I don't know what kind of penises
you've built in Minecraft but I probably
built some better ones just saying
uh-huh not I'm not trying to throw down
or anything or compare but I'm just
saying I the title to you thank you good
sir
oh god what the oh it's the thing that
just blew out of me and you weren't
paying attention
no I was it did it happen was it funny
but everybody was just a spirit thing
that blew through um so you'd like that
the cross is like not they just didn't
fun we're gonna pretend like they did
okay is there a way to get around
whatever yes we will be fine do not
worry about us
alright mister mister jump-scare
professional yes I mean all the jump
scares are triggering it Hey look at
that oh god that Boston accent are you
going Christopher Walken Chris you don't
want to hear my Christopher Walken do it
do it I Christopher Walken hey what's
the deal with a plain food this bad ah
Christopher Walken let's go down those
stairs works oh I bet I bet knowing -
they're happy
thank you oh so much fun so much fun
oh so much fun okay so anyway what we
need to do Isis man who's he 11
righteous man whose heart rots in South
oh that's good he heads west just to
find his family killed open these
bathroom doors if you dare her oh I bet
they have nothing scary in them nothing
nothing scary is that oh I thought maybe
that would be a cross no it's just
bathroom graffiti alpha and something
bloody I mean well it was Hawk I didn't
hear a hawk alright go down that hallway
oh okay oh there's a cross no they did
spawn oh wow that's amazing good for us
we actually what do we do I need to wash
it do I need to wash it yes wash The
Devil's cross to clean it there you go
you broke it apparently you heard the
scream of The Devil's cross being broken
the curse has lifted go on my child and
be free and oh no more wait did I did it
how many woo wasn't it five is five and
we've broken
um three I think we use a lot more ropes
shut up let's just keep moving shut up
stop questioning the Gabe keep movin
I've opened the door seven nine maybe we
should go into those probably its lights
liked but you know we ever knew how
about we going through here Oh lock - oh
yeah oh that's right cuz apparently the
clues of the poem down there are is for
something for this job wow wow you're
you're like that's why you're a
professional gamer right oh oh I'm so
great
oh and everything you do Kevin farkles
what
there's a baby it's lemon I think that's
a nice baby you want my baby
it's missing an arm but is that a fishel
offer yeah you can have my baby have all
my babies I'll take your baby
markiplier have my babies oh so much
fanfiction oh it's gonna go great
every time every time I play with
someone tumblr is like just not that I
don't like my fans out there but you
ship it I do not ship it I ship nothing
no come back come back oh you have gone
that room Oh duh no no okay go in this
room hang on we need to get something
from here we do yeah we need to get some
classroom is that there's a red button
it looks like I should press it it
didn't do nothing so how about we move
either way we're supposed to go all
right why is this not want to give me a
wire because these machines have never
worked not even the regular half life so
I mean come on Wow okay I'm gonna take
this one
oh okay you can you can take the lead
sure why is it I don't remember
was this person digested yes we're in
the stomach of the devil Anna I'm gonna
give him small sins oh man so many
others I'm sorry buddy
Oh God pit illegally little crowbar is
gonna not get a get monsters
okay fine he's getting ulcers from your
grenade Hey look another group another
cross break it woo oh yeah okay I do you
want to break it yo I didn't realize
this was Reagan yes that's what we're
doing okay um I think we can we got
unlocked seven to nine I believe so we
can move forward into the Jesus no
foreshadowing from you what so no fine
no I really thought that happened when
you went in not out
okay whoops oh my mistake
all right I think this door leads to
seven to nine okay
wait this is different though Oh change
No hey that's the last one I believe I
broke it
I'm breaking the devil's Horcruxes it's
the devil Voldemort I mean yes he who
must not be named I don't know if
there's anything in here no it doesn't
look like it hey it's good they go to
the bathroom okay all right
sorry did a hot pepper game radio and it
was oh it went right through me did it
have you seen those by the way hot
pepper game reviews I yeah no wait I
haven't but I know I've heard of it
oh yeah I did one it was so funny but so
unpleasant at the time what kind of what
kind of pepper do you have I ate a
habanero do you like special stuff I'm
not that spicy no okay yeah so it was
pretty bad and another one's coming out
and that text that you heard from me was
Vernon the guy who runs it telling me
hit mines coming up on Monday okay whoa
it's his arms on oh oh this is the door
to 7:00 and 9:00 that's right okay so we
go oh yeah we were never supposed to
unlock it at all wait how are it so we
there was like a puzzle with the button
thing that was yeah but yeah like nah
yeah we went around yeah all right oh hi
there bad news that thing just floated
at me please
oh yeah not bad you know loud noises
okay I should we go in here yeah we
should check it out maybe I need to find
some more Devil's crosses oh there's
roughly one in here someone doesn't seem
happy
one yeah there is oh wow that's other
poor cracks oh maybe maybe I broke it I
heard some he mad he mad bro the devil
made braids are you sure you're alone
wherever you are even though it's
probably bright day wherever you are cuz
you'll play it dark this should I
I don't have no it's pretty right out
look out behind you
I mean IRL okay shot but nevermind not
security look I'm sorry
ZV and you could actually accomplish
something like that that would be very
very much I would love that but my
horror skills are not that high yes you
can't like teleport yourself behind
someone not yet anyway not yet okay what
what did you think of slender you played
it right I did I had one particular
jump-scare in it that was just good oh
jeez it was really like bad and I was
like God I played it at midnight - and
good and I was yeah did you just play
the original eight pages there's been a
ton of different tyno there have been so
many okay moving moving on what what you
like my hat oh yeah - yeah everybody's
gonna want this oh alright let's go
alright now we can drop down go back cuz
we should have we broken all of it
there's no heart we're in the barrier
okay we need to go back this way through
the storage again okay oh wait no we
didn't go back here sorry there's one oh
wait did you see that no I didn't see it
Oh something spot like right on top of
me no no way so who's weird all right
one oh it's the control room see I agree
I everything was just haha
[Music]
my grams and CG was all being controlled
from years nothing is really like trying
to kill us
oh it was just old man Smithers the
entire time yeah you know gotten it away
was it to our kids
it wasn't for you meddling piece of
flesh and bone and muscle
all right go in that room okay I'm gonna
go in why why would you take it why
don't you take a shower in yellow stuff
sorry that was me um you might not want
to stand in that like fetch through my
old memories is too a name for there's
some like in chemistry there was some
yellow substance that uh was very
poisonous but we used it in chemistry
and and I was trying to fetch that name
it was something like led with letter it
was like potassium iodine or something
there's no soul ed legs it's been a long
time since my organic chemistry class
all right dropped out of that hole wait
where I'm staying up here I'm rude rude
it's just a shame you can't die I mean
oh no that monster in the sewers is good
good us a worrisome but oh you were
supposed to die to that yeah it was a
die cuz it came right behind you and now
it's patrolling its bow that is Jesus oh
it's a good thing that the gmod settings
won't let us like yeah you know die
anyway or not or we're just so good are
things okay apparently they're all right
buttons no there are clues all around
here and wow you did it whoa wow you're
really doing the clues no come back here
no one you knew you needed you randomly
hit the buttons in the correct order
that opened a half the door okay no
goodbye okay good you're good job thanks
man
my math job you must be really good at
games pretty good at games
good that's why you're so popular man oh
man okay all right so there's just one
last door
is it the final countdown it's a fire
don't be another button I hope it's not
oh wait yeah that's it did I win the
game yes you did it good job thank you
are a pro games see now I can just take
over the crown as reigning jump-scare
champion happy Halloween everyone
yeah happy Halloween that actually is
right around the corner so uh I wasn't
even thinking of that yeah so anyway
what do you think of the gaming like as
it is I thought it was very scary
like that pumpkin over there it's
probably the most terrifying part of the
whole that's pretty terrifying pumpkin I
guess say what you liked it jump scares
oh I think I can get used to the jump
scares well you don't want to get you
see the jump cures but that doesn't that
doesn't make sense you don't want it
yeah okay yeah you're horrible these
outro so anyway who's everybody like
comment and subscribe if you like
Junkers like comments or Fri okay I know
I know okay well this has been me
captain sparkles and and markiplier yes
and hopefully you've enjoyed and you can
you can watch marks perspective of me
being scared it's really funny
thanks for watching everyone thanks
see you next time
[Music]
right
what was that pretty very ugly guy
[Music]
dental job